[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute gibt es auf meinem kanal ein
leckeres dessert video und zwar ein
blauer schokoladen bisher
ich habe hier in fünf bläsern dieses
dessert drin und habe ich die blau creme
mit leckerem joghurt oben die
schokoladencreme mit sahne und
frischkäse und es ist genau nach meinem
geschmack denn es schmeckt nicht so süß
das ist einfach herzustellen und
allgemein mag ich löffel des herbst
gerne weil man sich so vereinfacht
zubereiten kann im kühlschrank lagern
kann und dann wenn man besucht hat oder
wenn man traut lust hat und gegessen hat
kann man sich das sehr schnell anrichten
denn murat wir und das gemeine größeren
star geworden kann man auch in einer
größeren schule machen oder in ganz
normalen trinkgläsern habe ich es früher
auch immer gemacht mittlerweile habe ich
einfach so ein paar verschiedene
weckgläser verlesen weil es einfach
hübscher aussehen also starten wir
gleich mal mit der blaubär schicht und
ich zeige euch davor noch mal die
zutaten für die blauen berg den brauche
ich 300 gramm blau.de bahnnetz
tiefgefroren und sind aufgetaucht 5
gramm aka aka das ist ein teelöffel 50
milliliter wasser 250 gramm joghurt da
habe ich einen zehnprozentigen joghurt
schön stichfest 2 sv puderzucker und
eine unbehandelte limite ich nehme jetzt
erstmal die blaue wand
die kommen jetzt in einem mixer mit dazu
und west jetzt erst noch fein pürieren
[Musik]
die masse fülle ich jetzt in einem topf
da kommt das agate sorgt die für die
bindung und es ruhig jetzt ein und
machte zwei minuten sprudelnd aufkochen
[Musik]
in der zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal
den joghurt verrühren und seitdem ich
immer gerne den joghurt den wels richtig
schön cremig natürlich könnt ihr auch
eine mit 35 prozent nehmen aber dann ist
der verminderten nicht hinkriegen da
gebe ich den puderzucker mit reinen
perfekt zum blaubär geschmack passt
natürlich einige nette da habe ich jetzt
die schale fein ab und gibt dann auch
den saft mit dazu
[Musik]
den joker drohe jetzt kurz durch
die bahn habe ich jetzt vom herd
heruntergezogen und lasso ein paar
minuten abkühlen
bis sie nur noch lauwarm sind denn die
laufen dann lauer sind gebe ich jetzt
ein paar löffel von der joghurt creme in
tegel auch wenn mit rein damit einfach
die masse jetzt nicht so schnell
verliert und die fülle ich dann zum
joghurt mit dazu
[Musik]
die masse können sie jetzt schon
abschrecken einfach mal schauen ob sich
süß genug ich wenn ich geb dir noch
einen esslöffel butter zucker mit dazu
jetzt nehme ich hier sechs gläser
und jetzt fühle ich die masse in meiner
kleinen dis ag sein
[Musik]
die bauwerte selbst habe ich jetzt schon
seit einer stunde im gefrierfach sowie
die blaue beim wasserfest und jetzt
werde ich eine schokoladencreme zu
bereiten
dafür brauche ich eine 175 gramm
frischkäse im doppel rahmen stufe 100 km
herren schokolade ein stück butter
diesen fünf gramm etwa ein bis zwei
esslöffel butter zucker und 200
milliliter sahne schokolade stelle ich
jetzt auf ein warmes wasserbad da kann
sie nämlich schmelzen und nehme jetzt
schon mal die sahne und werden sie halb
steif schlagen
das heißt nicht ganz stolz sondern nur
so dass es ein bisschen noch flüssig
bleibt
[Musik]
ich gehe jetzt erstmal mit frischkäse in
eine rührschüssel die pro tag gebe ich
jetzt noch hier mit schokolade
damit sie auch schmilzt
und ich nehme hier immer ganz gerne
herren schokolade weil die 60 prozent
kakaoanteil hat und somit habe ich den
folgen schokoladengeschmack und die
cremes zu süß
[Musik]
denn nochmal extrakt rein und ich werde
keinen zucker verwenden ich mag es gerne
nicht so süß aber falls euch die cre
ebenso nicht süß genug ist könnt ihr
gerne noch im betrieb oder zucker mit
einfügen und das ganze jetzt kurz
verrühren
wundert euch ist wahrscheinlich nochmal
detaillierten handrührgerät naja ich
habe einfach mal gesagt ich habe auf
euren tipp von auf euren rat und ja man
kann auch alles mit dem handrührgerät
machen deswegen verwende ich sollte aber
jetzt hätte ich bin unterzugehen
ich habe schon einmal benutzt
[Musik]
gut durch gerührt und jetzt muss ich nur
die sahne unterheben
die macht die ganze creme so ein
bisschen lockerer und die röhre ich
jetzt bei niedriger stufe noch kurz ein
[Musik]
die creme fühle ich jetzt in einen
spritzbeutel mit einer großen loch thüle
wenn ihr keinen spritzbeutel und keine
leute habt könnt ihr auch einen
gefrierbeutel nehmen oder auch die
kriegen einfach mitten im löffel drauf
geben
[Musik]
und so kann ich es jetzt in den lesern
verteilen
[Musik]
und jetzt nämlich noch ein paar
blaubeeren und paar minzblättern und ein
paar mikadostäbchen in weiß und dunkel
und werde es deshalb 19 aus die quere
[Musik]
jetzt ist das dessert fertig ihr müsst
nur daran denken ich hatte es jetzt noch
ein bisschen im gefrierfach weil ich
einfach schöne fotos machen wollte aber
ihr müsst natürlich nur am anfang kurz
im gefrierfach lassen und am besten
salat isst dann kühlschrank kalt also
nicht gefroren meint ich es noch ein
bisschen kalt aber lieber morath
es war einfach ein schöner und ihr seht
schon ich habe schon also eine karte
steht hier nämlich das ist ein trick
dadurch soll den zuschauern zeit weil
hier so schön ich hab's einfach weg
getrennt
ich habe das war doch weil ich da
ausgelöffelt habe die anderen sind 360
grad schön kochen hier 360
wenn man natürlich jetzt größere gläser
hat sind für 4 portionen und wenn man
kleine rad sind sechs portionen zeigt
bis zum 15
die zuschauer schon bereit schmidt echt
lecker gulasch diese blaubeeren von
alimera genau die süße schokolade oder
so ist auch interviews herpe von der
schokolade denn ich finde herr in
schokolade einfach perfekt da gibt es
nichts besseres
und wenn ihr es gerne etwas süßes haben
möchten wie gesagt ein bisschen zucker
zufügen aber ich mache das wirklich
gerne so gut geld so voran wie vor allem
super einfach und lecker falls ihr das
bisher nach machen wollt geht auch celis
- plock der etat steht es noch mal für
euch und gerne dürfte es nach machen und
uns ein foto schicken auf facebook oder
auf instagram uns verlinken ich schaue
da immer mal gerne eure fotos durch und
maike und kommentiert sind natürlich
auch also viel spaß beim nachmachen
morath genießt noch weiter und ich
stelle die restlichen engel schauen so
günstig die frau wird schon mit aber wie
gesagt der recht komplett im kühlschrank
kann auf kühlschranktemperatur kommune
die später gemeinsam ein schönes macht
sein buch den stäbchen von ballack
runtergefahren
[Musik]
geht euch fest